Robert said the senior fellow at the
Casimir Pulaski foundation in Poland
hello to you so thanks for joining us on
the program this morning your reaction
to the news that's been developing
overnight
good morning well let me clarify one
thing it's it's it's not the polls that
keep coming Daniel suggested I mean you
know there's been various reports uh you
know some of them contradictory the
truth is that we we have a war ongoing
Europe and that's the war which is waged
by Russia against Ukraine and you know
this missile attacks barbaric against
you know civilian targets that have been
happening before uh so uh whether it is
the actual Russian missile uh the Polish
foreign Ministry of saman the Russian
Ambassador quite rightly is saying it's
a Russian May uh missile whether this is
a Russian missile which directly sort of
speak travel to Poland whether it's a
Russian missile which was uh you know
diverted it's caused by the greatest or
even if it was a Ukrainian elephants
missile which was trying to defend of
course Ukraine against this attack which
trade and unfortunately killed the
Polish citizens it is still the case
that this type of situation would not
arise if it was if it was not for The
Reckless barbaric war that Russia is
waging every day you know I mean uh more
than half I believe in happiness of Kiev
have been without electricity and
heating throughout the night this is the
reality and you know NATO has to be
involved because this is an extremely
serious situation the one that you know
uh both Poland and NATO as such has
warned Russia against and you know we
would not be even discussing this sort
of issue if Russia stopped the war
stopped the missile attacks so this is
really the the focus that we should take
and as it happens apart from the NATO
meeting which should start indeed in an
hour and two hours time uh there is also
a new crane defense uh support to
Ukraine coordinating meeting which we'll
discuss further support Ukraine
including let's hope more uh defense
systems more uh type of equipment which
will help Ukraine to defend itself but
also uh will actually make other the
country safer because you know this
situation is intolerable it's um you
know I mean for British U.S imagine if
there was a missile uh which suddenly
hit a part of Cornwell or you know
Aberdeen et cetera I mean this this
cannot go on but the clue uh the key to
this lies in Russia stopping it and it
seems at the moment the best way to stop
it is to ensure that Ukraine achieves a
victory on the battlefield because it is
winning this war yeah I suppose the most
pressing question overnight though is is
what's happened uh on polish soil
triggering articles four and five of the
NATO agreement in your opinion
I think we're quite far away from
Article Five because you know that would
involve you know premeditated consistent
attack the Polish president last night
said that you know there are all the
signs that this was and and you know
hopefully isolated incident but
nevertheless it is serious because you
know a security of one Ally is a
security uh of others too and you know
uh
Poland is is actually being very uh
diligent in terms of not uh raising the
stakes not going for any kind of you
know escalation but wants to get to the
bottom of it they are actually also
later on America specifically experts
which which are part of investigation
and uh all the I would say proper if you
like political and security policy
procedures are being followed because
nobody is interested in escalation but
at the same time put yourself in a
situation of uh of the people uh living
in Poland and frankly other countries
like Baltic states who are very close to
this Frontline not to mention the
Ukrainian themselves this cannot go on
Russia cannot be threatening and causing
this type of habit and and Factor
directly or indirectly killing people in
Europe today so uh there have to be even
more efficient ways to improve our
security but also to prevent Russia to
make it impossible for Russia to uh to
continue and frankly any statements
emanating from Russia at this stage
should be treated with uh you know with
you know more than a caution because we
know for a fact that Russia has been
engaged in this information lying at the
highest level for a very long time
you're referring of course there to the
former Russian president Medvedev who's
saying that we're edging ever closer to
another world war you talked about the
situation in Poland and other countries
that are bordering um the bordering
Russia what more can be done to keep the
people of those countries safe
well I think again I've already alluded
to this I mean we the Paradox is this
that although Ukraine is not a member of
data if you ask a lot of people they
will say it should be but it's not but
the fact though it is the country that
is by defending itself very heroically
but also very uh you know effectively it
is actually uh you know doing probably
the most to uh to guarantee to help the
security of the rest of Europe
and we still have some kind of an
ongoing debate uh you know in which some
countries uh UK by the way is is an
exemplary Ally because it has been
extremely supportive of Ukraine in a
variety of ways but also you know a
stone channel for Poland and there are
many others but then there's still some
reluctance to for instance provide uh
the necessary additional uh you know
equipment to Ukraine as far as countries
like Poland which is a frontier State
well I think uh perhaps um you know uh
additional stationing of fighter planes
from other NATO countries additional
elements of the of the air defense
equipment would be an order and perhaps
there's also a time to revisit the issue
of at least thinking about a possible uh
you know
you know essentialization of some kind
of a no-fly zone because again I stress
you know this cannot happen this this
should not be repeated and Russia has to
be uh you know has to be made to
understand that this is reckless and you
know uh while nobody wants of course any
escalation uh but at the same time you
know uh this type of behavior because
again uh it is Russian actions which
lead to this uh will not be tolerated
this is the message which should go out
from all the capitals of of Europe and
uh and North America and Beyond